up tonight game three of the Stanley Cup
Final for the golden Knight Vegas can
take a commanding three games to none
lead in the series tonight against the
Florida Panthers as Logan Reaver
explains from Miami the team knows the
job is not done yet
hey good morning guys as we know the
knights have gotten used to playing in
hectic environments this postseason
whether it be the double overtime game
winner in Winnipeg outclassing Edmonton
twice on their home ice or saving their
best performance of the season for that
six nothing closeout win in Dallas all
of it has resulted in a 6-2 record away
from home this postseason but all of
that will hail in comparison to the
Bedlam they are about to experience here
in Florida in just a couple of hours
especially with the Panthers team whose
calling card is never being dead and we
got to learn from what will happen last
series right we're up through nothing
and we lost two games after so uh that's
something that we've got to take a lot
of pride a little bit more Pride to with
every game the series goes on the
urgency has to keep you know I'm ramping
up right in and you know you're
obviously going to get their best games
and and uh you know we got to keep doing
the things that have been making us
successful you know we certainly have
fun we're Hooten and hollering and
um you know if you watch practice today
you could probably hear it you know
speaking know marchy he was miked up
today but it doesn't take a mic in order
for him to be hurt Alec Martinez
emphasized that being on the road has
brought this group closer together
whether it be cornhole Connect Four or
ax throwing which he says it's not a
relaxed don't worry about that but all
of it has directly correlated in more
chemistry on the ice Martinez saying
this is a special group and that they
genuinely love each other
from South Florida Logan Reaver eight
Sports now